Today is not a day like any other, and I'm
not I'm not doing a Passover Sader, I know
many of my friends will recognize that line
from Passover.
No, today is not a day like any other for
different reasons.
Yesterday, yes, Donald Trump spoke publicly
again.
Yes.
We are going to discuss it.
Yes, I am going to play some clips.
But Donald Trump has now gone over a line
where he is just five and a half weeks away
from the election, refusing to say that there
will be a peaceful transition of power.
Should he lose, he will not commit to a peaceful
transition.
Now, when you combine this with our earlier
story from the top of the show about Donald
Trump's contingency plan for how to retain
power, even if he loses, you have to at this
point start paying attention.
This was a press briefing.
I guess it was sort of under the umbrella
of a corona virus press briefing, although
on Corona virus, Trump says the same thing
every time, which is we're doing great.
Everything's fine.
On the virus.
And then the questions started from the press
corps and Donald Trump was asked, will you
commit to a peaceful transfer of power?
And Donald Trump refuses to commit to it.
And he's a wannabe dictator.
And we should all be very, very scared.
Well, are all in this election.
Will you commit here today for a peaceful
transfer of power after the election?
There has been rioting a level.
There's been rioting in many cities across
this country, bread and your so-called red
and blue states.
Will you commit to making sure that there
is a peaceful transfer for all of power after
the election?
Have to see what happens.
You know that I've been complaining very strongly
about the ballots and the ballots are a disaster
and that people are rioting.
Do you commit to making sure that there's
a place where we want to get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very transfer?
We'll have a very peaceful.
There won't be a transfer, frankly.
There'll be a continuation.
The ballots are out of control, you know.
And you know, who knows it better than anybody
else?
The Democrats know it better than anybody
else.
Now, the guy asking the questions saying,
hey, but people are rioting.
So will you commit to a peaceful transition?
It's actually a non sequitur.
And, you know, we have protests that are mostly
peaceful and now there is unrest because of
what's going on with Briona Taylor in Kentucky,
which we already talked about.
I don't really love the framing of will you
commit to a peaceful transfer of power because
there are riots.
It's like, well, hold on.
Will you commit to a peaceful transfer of
power is really the full question.
You don't need anything else with it.
But this is the red alert.
The reaction from Donald Trump, we don't have
to speculate that Donald Trump might not leave
or will try not to leave to be.
To be clear, because he's saying it in broad
daylight, I have to see the results first
before I commit to a peaceful transfer of
power, even if I lose.
When Trump says the way it will be peaceful
is if we don't have the ballots.
He's referring to vote absentee by mail, which
Trump thinks would lead to him winning.
He is essentially saying if the results are
that I won, we will have a peaceful transition
in that there will be no transition, because
if the election is fair, I will win.
This is an extraordinarily dangerous thing
to say.
Are all standard bullet points apply?
Everybody has to vote.
This is not a rehearsal.
This is happening.
He's doing it.
It's outrageous.
And it it didn't get any less crazy.
Just a couple of other clips.
Donald Trump was told during the briefing
that Prince Harry and Meghan Markle will not
be supporting him.
And Trump just insults Meghan Markle.
Prince Harry and Becky Marcal chimed in on
the U.S. election, essentially encourage people
to vote for Joe Biden.
Your reaction to that?
I'm not a fan of hers.
And I would say this, and she probably has
heard that.
But I wish a lot of luck to her.
She's going to need it.
This is a president speaking this way.
And then Trump brings up and we'll discuss
this later, that mixing the flu with the China
virus, as he calls it, will be interesting.
The flu, when it's mixed with Kofod China
virus is going to be very interesting to see
what happens.
But interesting is certainly an interesting
way to describe it.
And then even the end of this press briefing
is wild.
Trump abruptly says, as the questions start
coming in about Briona Taylor, Trump says
he has to go take an emergency phone call
and walks away.
And when reporter John Roberts asks him who's
the phone call with, Trump just says it's
very important for an emergency phone call.
I'm going to let Larry.
So I'll be I'll be back.
I will see you tomorrow day.
Time right now.
American person, we are on alert.
OK, so that's just a little bit of the the
the flavor.
The tone.
But the big thing here is Donald Trump is
refusing to say he will leave peacefully if
he loses.
The man has come to the end of the line and
he knows Biden could win.
Biden could win.
And he is going to pull out all the stops
and see if he can get away with it.
And why wouldn't he?
He's gotten away with so much so far.
Why wouldn't he try it?
And the ironic thing is we talk about projection
constantly.
If Biden wins, Trump will call that a coup.
That's what Trump will say is a coup.
They will always accuse you of what they are
actually doing.
Now, the truth here is Donald Trump has always
had this perspective.
What I mean is Trump still hasn't accepted
the results of 2016 when he won.
Trump still does not accept that he really
lost to Hillary by millions of votes.
He continues to say, well, I won electorally,
hugely.
And even on the popular vote, it was rigged.
Busses from Massachusetts to New Hampshire,
it's like, well, hold on.
What what what are you talking about?
How would that how would that even affect
the popular vote?
First of all, if people are voting in the
wrong state.
But in any case, he still has not accepted
the results of an election he won.
Democracy is really at risk here.
And certainly Donald Trump will do everything
he can not to accept the results of an election
if he loses.